good evening bonsoir as minister of
National Defense my top priority is the
safety and protection of Canadians
working in collaboration with our
partners including the United States
NORAD and other departments Canada was
tracking a high altitude object over
Central Yukon
North American Aerospace Defense command
detected this object and launched
Canadian and U.S fighter aircraft to
investigate the object was visually
identified using fighter aircraft
assigned to NORAD
affected
this exemplifies what NORAD is and what
Nora does best and I was pleased to
discuss this operation earlier today
with my colleague United States
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
today
at the direction of the Prime Minister
aircraft assigned to NORAD successfully
took down this high altitude Airborne
object at approximately 3 41 PM Eastern
Standard Time
foreign
[Music]
to the best of our knowledge this was
the first time that a NORAD operation
has downed an aerial object
the object was flying at an altitude of
approximately 40
000 feet had unlawfully entered Canadian
airspace and posed a reasonable threat
to the safety of Civilian flight
the object was downed approximately 100
miles from the Canada United States
border over Canadian territory in
central Yukon
altitude is
about you UConn
recovery operations are now underway and
will be supported by the Canadian Armed
Forces in conjunction with the RCMP
this coordinated operation will allow a
further investigation into this object
we have no further details about the
object at this time other than it
appears to be a small cylindrical object
and smaller than the one that was downed
off the coast of North Carolina
I also spoke today with UConn Premier
ranj Palais and conveyed that we will
continue to work hand in hand with the
territory
I and our government will continue to
reach out to indigenous peoples
potentially affected by this incident to
provide information and updates as
needed out of respect for reconciliation
today is an historic day
Canada and the United States will
continue to work together through the
bi-national command of NORAD to defend
our two Nations and I will recognize
again the importance of this extremely
close relationship that we have with the
United States is
just yesterday I was in the United
States meeting with Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin at the Pentagon where we
reaffirmed that North American Air
sovereignty is a key priority which is
why we continue to work in partnership
with the United States NORAD and the
broader security Community to protect
Canadian and U.S interests we will
continue our work to modernize NORAD and
to ensure the protection of our air
sovereignty and I will be seeing
secretary Austin again next week
through NORAD we will continue to work
hand in hand with our closest Ally to
ensure the protection of our continent
as we showed today I thank all members
of our military
and the United States involved in this
operation
news
thank you merci make watch
ES
how are you
um this is the third such incident uh in
this past week uh this uh object was
down because there was considered a
threat to safety should Canadians be
worried and my following question is is
anything being done to monitor our
airspace and
let me assure all Canadians that
Canadians are safe there is no reason to
believe that the impact of the object in
Canadian territory is of any public
concern the Canadian Armed Forces with
the RCMP will recover and will analyze
the object and in terms of tracking and
a process going forward I want to assure
all Canadians that this is the job of
NORAD this is exactly what NORAD was
intended to do and this is exactly what
we saw today occurring the surveillance
and the analysis of objects of concern
in our Aerospace and then decisions that
are made
bi-nationally and in this instance by
our prime minister to take this object
down
so the process
is sound and we will continue to work
very closely with our U.S allies and
nochad to make sure that it continues to
work in this way as I said to our
knowledge this is the first instance of
NORAD Downing an object in Canadian
airspace and the importance of this
moment should not be underestimated we
detected this object together and we
defeated this object together do you
think link over your counterparts in the
U.S do you think that it possibly could
have originated in China
at this point
we are continuing to do the analysis on
the objects and we will make sure that
that analysis is thorough
and so it would not be prudent for me to
speculate on the origins of the object
at this time however I will say that we
are continuing to work closely with our
NORAD
partners and our U.S partners and we
will make sure that we leave no stone
unturned in the analysis of the data
that we are now going to be turning to
analyze
Clarity I know you mentioned that it was
downed with by U.S and Canadian fighter
jets uh is that is that correct is that
my interest because I thought it might
just be U.S fighter jets
so these assets that were deployed were
part of the NORAD capabilities and they
included two F-22 from the United States
and two f-18s from Canada we also have a
CP 140 in the air to pinpoint the
location of the debris and to assist
with the next steps in the analysis and
evaluation but as I said this was a
joint operation the decision to take
down the object was made by the Prime
Minister he spoke with the president of
the United States this afternoon I also
spoke with my counterpart secretary
Austin to ensure that we were all
aligned and indeed we were on the need
to have a successful engagement and
indeed to employ Nora NORAD to do
exactly what it is intended to do
I know you mentioned that it's too early
to say Obviously where this object is
from that's part of your investigation
in terms of analyzing it if it is found
to have originated in China what do you
think the potential impact could be with
regards to our diplomatic relations I
think it's fair to say they've been
Rocky
so again I will not be speculating on
the origins of this object this evening
it is far too early in our analysis of
the debris as we are still collecting
we're working to collect it as I said in
the in conjunction with the RCMP
so
that's the first point the second point
is that in our indo-pacific strategy
released uh
late last year
we did indicate that we need to be Eyes
Wide Open on China
and we will continue to do that through
the policy framework of the indo-pacific
strategy but also again in conjunction
with our allies in support of a
transparent and
and present indo-pacific
[Music]
one of these balloons they said they
called it a Chinese surveillance balloon
China pushed back saying it was a
weather balloon what is Canada's
position
this is an object
this is a cylindrical object that we
shot down today it appears to be a
cylindrical object and we are working to
analyze the debris to identify more
specifics about this object
it appears to be smaller in size than
the one that the United States shot down
off the core coast of North Carolina
last week
but at this point that is the
information that I can share
I think the importance of today's
successful Mission underscores
the
functionality
of NORAD
the only bi-national
command in the world that has kept us
safe
for 40 years or more
and our government announced last year
that we will be modernizing and
upgrading our Continental defense
including NORAD that's going to include
constructing a new surveillance system
called the northern approaches
surveillance system that's going to
include enhancing command and control
that's going to include ensuring greater
research and development in this area
so this goes to show that Nora is
functioning as it should and we
recognize the need to enhance the
technology that underpins
Aerospace surveillance
thanks Minister and we'll take another
question to follow up
as a reminder please unmute yourself if
you're on the line using star six do we
have any further questions from media
yeah any questions Steve Chase
go ahead Steve
hi Minister the sound has been really
bad for the journalists listening on the
phone or on zoom and so we missed some
key information that you gave out
because about half the audio was cutting
out oh I'm sorry about that I didn't
know that Steve
um so please uh go ahead and ask your
questions or I can say my whole speech
again if you like well I I'm I'm I'll
leave it to the rest of the journalists
on that I just wanted to ask you there
was key information what time was it
shot down where roughly
has the wreckage been found and could
you just explain what you said about the
shape of the object again and how it
compares to the last
um item shot down
okay
um here are the details
the object was shot down at
approximately 3 41 PM Eastern Standard
Time
the object was shot down in over Central
Yukon
and at about 40
000 feet
is that the detail you were looking for
Steve
yes and have you found the wreckage and
can you just describe it again you you
talked about something the shape of it
and you compared it to the previous uh
two items that were shot down in this
month
um so we have a CP 140
that is actively pinpointing the site of
the debris now
and so that is a process that is under
way given that this was just shot down
hours ago
but as I said it was shot down in
central Yukon so that is the area of
reconnaissance that the cp-140 is uh
is at
in terms of the description of the
object
we
believe that the object is cylindrical
in shape
it appears to be smaller than the one
that was shot down
off the coast of North Carolina
we are as I said
with Public Safety recovering the object
to discover more details including the
shape and the size of this object so we
will have more details to share in the
days to come but we wanted to share what
we know right now and that's what we're
doing
thank you Minister we'll take another
question from journalists on the line if
you're on the line please press star six
to unmute we'll go to the next question
now
sorry Lee go ahead okay thank you thanks
David
um I wanted to ask maybe a silly
question but I think it's on you know
didn't think I'd ever asked this
question is there any indication that
this object is not terrestrial is not
from this world
um or is it is it too really to say
anything about from
uh you're right I have not had that
question Lee so thank you for uh for
asking it uh there from all indications
uh this object is potentially similar to
the one that was shot down off the coast
of North Carolina those smaller in size
and cylindrical in nature that is the
information that we are working with
right now but with further analysis we
will know more and be able to provide
you with more details
and so just to confirm so it sounds like
it potentially was another balloon is
that uh is that what we're being led to
believe here I will refer to that the
item as an object at this time I am a
person that uh depends on facts and will
not provide uh opinions until I can
ground them in some sort of fact so I'm
going to wait for the reports that I
will be getting relating to the analysis
of the debris we have a cp140 in the air
ensuring that we are locating the debris
we have a very close relationship now
with Public Safety and Minister
Mendocino as well and I are working very
closely to make sure that the recovery
and the analysis proceeds as it must so
that we can get more information and I
will come back and provide more details
and more explanation once we have that
[Music]
Wall Street Journal
um
why did the U.S Fighters plane shoot
this down as opposed to Canadian
as opposed to
separating It Out by country I think
what the important point is is that
these were NORAD capabilities this was a
NORAD Mission and this was NORAD doing
what it is supposed to do and what we
wanted to do with the f-22s and the
f-18s is to make sure that we had
sufficient Assets in the air to ensure a
successful engagement and that in fact
was the tenor of my conversation with
the Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
this afternoon as well as my
conversation with the Prime Minister the
prime minister's main goal today was to
make sure that we got this object out of
the air and that we could analyze it and
that's exactly what happened through the
use of NORAD capabilities
and follow up
maybe I can just jump in here ministers
David Coleman with CBC News
[Music]
forgive me if um this was in the portion
before that we weren't able to hear but
are you able to just give us some where
did the aircraft launch from was it cold
lake and Elmendorf what was the weapon
system that was used to down this object
any kind of detail like that sure um we
had both U.S and Canadian assets
involved as I just described the f-22s
and the f-18s and the f-22s originated
in Elmdorf Richardson Alaska and our
f-18s from Cold Lake in Alberta and
we'll have to recognize that there our
contextual elements in the deployment of
aircraft in this particular instance
that we need to take note of first of
all visual citing when we first started
tracking this object it was dark and we
needed to make sure that we had a visual
of it and so needed to wait for daylight
to emerge secondly we needed to make
sure that there was infrared or missile
lock capability and that was something
that both the
f-22s and the F-18 Pilots were working
on together so as I said it was a NORAD
Mission it was NORAD capabilities and
our Armed forcers work very closely with
the U.S armed forces to ensure a
successful Downing of this object that
we had concern about for more more
specifics I will ask the chief of
Defense staff General Wayne Air who's
with me this evening if he would like to
add anything General Air
no thanks Minister and David to go to
the specifics of your question it was an
aim 9x missile from the F-22 now it's
important to note that the instructions
that were given to the the team was
whoever had the first best shot to take
out the uh the balloon uh had the
go-ahead it's also important to note
that all the aircraft were under the
direction of Canadian NORAD region so a
Canadian General in in Winnipeg
was was overseeing this this operation
albeit in a NORAD context you know I've
had multiple conversations with my U.S
counterpart General Mark milley today as
well as numerous briefings from a
commander and Deputy commander of NORAD
down in Colorado Springs to discuss all
aspects of this operation
thank you we'll take the next question
hi uh this is Cormac mix 20 with City
News can you hear me yes I can
um I the Liberal Party website has that
the Prime Minister was scheduled to be
holding a fundraising event in UConn
this weekend I believe it's supposed to
be held tomorrow is there any belief
from the government that this object
flying over Yukon and the prime
minister's presence in UConn at the same
time is a coincidence is is there some
relation there
uh I am aware that the scheduled
fundraiser
is on the books and indeed I spoke with
the Member of Parliament from UConn my
dear friend Brendan about this who's
looking forward to receiving the Prime
Minister uh we are not tracking at this
point uh information relating to the
object frankly we were concerned to get
it out of the sky and that was our Focus
all day and indeed in the past 24 hours
and so any further information will come
with the analysis that we are doing
regarding the debris
and in terms of the analyzing of the
wreckage you know the U.S is analyzing
its wreckage and we'll be analyzing ours
um I use I assume we'll be sharing
information between both governments but
will this go beyond just the U.S and
Canada what other countries might be
involved in examining this getting the
intelligence around this I assume the
five eyes allies but if you could
confirm that for us as well well this is
of course an issue of concern
to both Canada and the United States and
the analysis of the debris and the
information relating to that analysis
will I am sure be shared amongst all
parties concern uh NORAD
the relevant players in both the
Canadian and the U.S government so
there's
excellent cooperation amongst us all now
and this will continue as I said we
continue to reiterate the importance of
our collaboration relating to the
protection of the Skies over the North
American continent and that's exactly
what we are going to continue to do
in terms of the broader information
sharing possibility I will say that we
work extremely closely with our five
eyes allies and we certainly have been
doing so over the past year especially
and I will say that I will be at the
defense Minister's meeting in Brussels
next week and we will continue to share
information with our allies as necessary
again to ensure that we have accurate
information and that we are doing
whatever we can in the protection of our
allies more generally
thank you and we'll take a final
question now from the line uh please
press star six to unmute yourself thank
you
nobody else Minister and on um the news
nation in DC you you mentioned that we
were waiting for uh daylight uh for
sighting and for infrared missile lock
capability
I was that daylight not sufficient
enough to allow us to determine whether
or not this was a balloon or not
the
the importance of the visual sighting
and the infrared missile lock
again as you mentioned and as I
mentioned it's it's Paramount
but
the
purpose of the mission today was to take
down the object and it wasn't possible
to analyze that object at the exact same
time
and so
we are being extremely prudent and
careful relating to the next steps which
is why we're working the Canadian Armed
Forces are working so closely with the
RCMP and with Public Safety to ensure
that we extract the debris
that we analyze the debris and any
information that may be associated with
it so at this point we can say that it
appears to be a cylindrical object
smaller in size than the object that was
shot down off the coast of North
Carolina
and further details relating to this
object will be forthcoming as soon as we
have them
thank you
thank you very much
yeah
today's press conference thank you and
uh we will uh wish everyone a great
night
merci beaucoup thank you